اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاتي هذا المساء
لماذا يحرص النقيضان الكردي والتركي على
الهروله نحو نظام الاسد بحثا عن حديث ام
ابعاد دمشق عن معركه انقره المسلحين
الاكراد وفي الملف الثاني هل المخاوف
الامريكيه والعالميه من تحول تويتر
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل العلاقه مع دمشق هي
نقطه التقاء طرفين متصارعين هما تركيا
والاكراد فاكله الجانبين يهرولان نحو دمشق
قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي
قال انا بابهم مفتوح للقياده الدستوريه في
دمشق داعيا الجيش السوري معهم التصريحات
كانت لافته لانها جاءت تزامنا معرض
فيما كان رد فعل دمشق خجلا من ضربات جويه
وفقرهم ذلك على واقعه ملامحي تقارب كذلك
من جهه اخرى بين انقره ودمشق هذه المره
ابرزها ما قاله اردوغان مؤخرا بان احتمال
لقاء الاسد ممكن معتبرا انه لم جلاء في
السياسه ورجح محللون ان يحصل اللقاء بين
الاسد واردوغان قبل الانتخابات التركيه
المقرره في يونيو من
2320 وقد يستضيفه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتن لكن منذ نزل عن نزاع لم يدخل الاكراد
في مواجهه مباشره مع دمشق بينما اصطدمت
جولات من المحادثات بينهما بحائط مسدود
الذي يسر الاقراض على الحفاظ على مكتسباتي
ادارتهم ذاتيه غير ان دمشق ترفض ذلك تماما
وتحمل عليهم نزعتهم منفصاليه وتلقيهم دعما
من واشطا
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
دكتور بكير توجان مدير ومحدي اسطنبول
للفكره من اربيل محمود خشنه السياسي
الكردي ومن دمشق عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب
الصحفي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من اسطنبول معك دكتور بكير دكتور
بكير في الواقع رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان قرر مجموعه من الدعوات والتصريحات
يعني تحدث عن ان في السياسه لا خلافات
دائمه والاكيد بانك تبعت هذه التصريحات
تحدث بانه لا نقما في السياسه وبانه هناك
امكانيه للقاء الاسد كررها في فتره ضيقه
لمده ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا حتى لفتت البعض
فطرح سؤال
سارعت الاسد في مثل او في هذه الدعوه
لماذا يهرول همم ليس الاسد اردوغان عفوا
لماذا يهرول لقاء الاسد
يعني اولا همم في العالم كله في تغيرات
جذريه وخاصه في الشرق الاوسط
اصبحت حقيقه ايضا في هذه التغيير ولكن هذا
التغيير غير ممكن ان تكون وخاصه دول كانت
لها علاقات تاريخيه ثقافيه اجتماعيه وحتى
اقتصاديه وعسكريه همم جيده جدا في فترات
القادمه ان تكون يعني متروك على هذا الشكل
كما يقولون همم يدخل من يريد ويخرج من
يريد على المنطقه كلها فكان لابد همم
همم احدا ما من هؤلاء المسؤولين ان كان
سويا تركيا كرديا ان يقول همم بان لابد ان
ترجع العلاقات او ترجع همم الى ما كانت
عليه على الاقل
ولكن همم اعتقد
البدايه كانت من الطلب من تركيا لماذا من
تركيا لان عندما توافق او الاصح عندما
كانت
تركيا تريد او تسعى جاهزه الى وقفه اطلاق
النار في بين اوكرانيا وروسيا من طرف وبعض
الاتفاقيات الجديده بالنسبه للدول لكن نجد
تركيا بذاتها لها مشاكل
وخاصه شبيهه في اوكرانيا مع روسيا يعني
شبيهه في المنطقه حتى في ما يحصل همم لذلك
اذا
دوله جاده تريد الاصلاح وتريد علاقات جيده
مع جيرانها مع اخواتها مع المنطقه كلها
فلابد البدايه ان تكون من نفسها يعني من
تركيا وليس من دوله اخرى
وان كانت الدعوه من تركيا ولكن يجب ان
يكون هناك تبادل ايجابي همم لهذا الاطار
من العلاقات همم الاستاذ عبد الحميد هل
سوريا تبادل تركيا عوده متينه للعلاقات
كما يريدها اردوغان على الاقل همم عوده
خلينا نقول في هذه المرحله لقاءات على
اعلى مستوى همم لان تصريحات او موقف
النظام السوري قراه الباص او وصفه بالخجول
هل يتالم بشار الاسد يحسب حساب ماذا
مساء الخير لك يا ريم ولضيفيك الكريمين
والي ياساده المشاهدين اعتقد ان المساله
ليست مرتبطه بعواطف ولا مرتبطه بخجل هناك
معطيات على ارض الواقع برزت على في
العلاقه السوريه التركيه وهناك وجود تركي
همم عسكري رسمي
تصرفه دمشق بانه وجود احتلالي وهناك مناطق
تركيا وتحتلها وتشرف عليها وهناك فصائل
مسلحه معارضه سوريه ايضا تخضع لاراده
التركيه تدريبا واعدادا ورعايه وعلى كل
الصعد وكذلك هناك من المعطيات السياسيه
التي بدات تفعل فعلها في اطار هذه العلاقه
انا اعتقد بان الموقف السوري همم ليس
كجولا كما يقال ولكن هناك همم اسس لابد من
البناء عليها اذا ما ارادت هذه العلاقات
ان تعود الى سابق عهدها وانا اعتقد وهذا
وجدت نظري لان المعطيات الخائنه حاليا
معطيات يمكن وصفها بالمفخات الكبيره التي
تحتاج اولا الى نزع فتائلها وجود العسكري
التركي في المنطقه دعم الفصاله المسلحه
المعارضه وكذلك هل الاداره التي تقوم بها
تركيا لمناطق الشمال او مناطق كثير من
الشمال السيوري وصولا الى حمله تكريكا
حدثت في بعض المناطق وتغيير العمله
السوريه في تلك المناطق اعتقد بان الموقف
السوري يمكن تلخيصه بالاتي تنتظر سوريا
استجابه من الجانب التركي لتلبيه المطالب
ذات الطابع السيادي اولا ومن ثم السياد
السياسي ثانيا وعلى بناء على هذه الاجابات
التي يجب ان تكون واضحه كما تقول المصادر
الرسميه السوريه من الجانب التركي يمكن
البناء عليها حدثت لقاءات على المستوى
الامني برعايه الروسيه وبدفع الروسي همم
مبادره الروسيه ولكنها الى الان في
مراحلها الاولى الحديث عن عوده علاقات
متينه كما كانت اعتقد بان اي دولهتين
جارتين ترفضاني مثل هذه العلاقات وقبل همم
2011 همم باتت العلاقات السوريه التركيه
مضرب مثلا في المنطقه همم في كل المستويات
وصلت الى مرحله ان الغيت همم التاشيرات
ورفعت الحواجز بين الحدود وبات المواطن
التركي يدخل سوريا لهويته او جواز سفره هو
حر وكذلك المواطن السوري يدخل الى ارض
تركيا اعتقد بان هذا المطلب لديه هناك
محددات لا بد من تلبيتها وبضعها على سلم
التفاهم وبالتالي يمكن من خلالها البناء
عليها في المستقبل لاعاده علاقات المشتركه
بين الطرفين ولكن اعود اقول ان هناك كثير
من المعطيات همم الراهنه الان والتي فاتت
على
حميد
وانا ساكته بس منك استعير ملك هذا المصطلح
لانقله لضيف الاستاذ محمود ولكن همم استاذ
عبد الحميد تبدو اا رؤيتك واضحه للامور
افهم منك وهنا السؤال الحذرتك محمود بان
الجانب السوري همم وكانه يطرح ملفات
لمحاوله ايجاد حلول لها ومن بين هذه
الملفات الشائكه بين تركيا وبين النظام
السوري هو ملف الاقراض ضيفي حتى استخدم
مصطلح قوي يتحدث عن مناطق يستعمرها الجانب
التركي همم في سوريا فهل تعاون فعليا على
النظام الاسد ليكون وسيط بين الطرفين رغم
خلافاتكم التاريخيه معه ولكن كان هناك
تقارب ليه فترات واهم هذه الفترات الحرب
ضد داعش وحتى في 2019 كان مثل هكذا تقارب
ضد تركيا هل يمكن ان يعيد التاريخ نفسه
احييكي وزملائي الضيوف ومشاهدي العربيه
حقيقه يجب ان نحدد اطراف الصراع والاطراف
المختلطه في هذا الصراع صراحه هناك ثلاث
اطراف سوريه محليه النظام السوري اي
الحكومه السوريه وايضا اا قصد القوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وايضا قوه اخرى تميل
الى تركيا التي هي المعارضه السوريه ايضا
اطراف خارجيه روسيا امريكا ايران هذه
الاطراف ايضا لديها دور في المعادله
السياسيه بما يتعلق بشمال شرق سوريا او
حتى في العمق السوري وما يتعلق حتى في
شمال العراق المناطق كردستان العراق وايضا
معادله لربما هي قديمه جديده او ان نستطيع
ان نقول بان هذا النزاع قديم جديد في
ارتباطات كثيره في اقتصاد فيها سياسه في
امن قومي يعني كثير من العوامل تؤثر على
هذه العلاقه ليس بهذه السهوله ان يتم
تطبيع العلاقه بين سوريا وتركيا نعم هناك
مشتركات بين سوريا وتركيا بما يتعلق
بالكره يعني على سبيل المثال المشتركات ان
كل ما كانت الحركه الكوريه لان ان افاق
الحل السياسي بين القوى السوريه مع
الحكومه السوريه او النظام السوري باتت
معدومه شبه معدومه لان استراحه هي الخلافه
على الاولويات ما هي الاولويات في التعامل
مع بعض لذلك انا اعتقد بان الدوله الروسي
في تقريب وجهات النظر او محاوله للقاء
القمه بين الرئيسين اردوغان وبشار الاسد
ضربه ما هي الاقرب اقرب السيناريات حضوره
صراحه كانوا وما زالوا ضحيه بغض النظر عن
الحزب العمال الكردستاني الاتحاد الوطني
الحزب الديمقراطي والكردستاني الاخرى سواء
تركيا رفضتهم مقابلتهم سوريا رفضتهم او
مقابلتهم الحكومات العراقيه قبلتهم ام
رفضتهم وكذلك ايران هناك تقارب في وجهات
النظر بين ايران العراق سابقا وسوريا
وتركيا في التعامل مع هذا القضيه شامل
لاطراف اخرى ولكن في هذا الفصل همم هل
يمكن ان يعول الاكراد استاذ محمود على
النظام السوري همم اعلم بانه هناك اطراف
وتحدثت على الضغط او على الاقل تاثير
الروسي ولكن هل نظام الاسد قادر ان اا
يؤثر ان يضغط تعتقدون بان الاكراد يمكن ان
يعاونوا عليه هذا سؤال
واضح جدا
نظام السوري او حكومه الاسد اذا ارادت ان
تستخدم الورق الكرديه في عهد الوضع
الطبيعي لحدوديه الشماليه الشرقيه مع
تركيا وايضا تركيا تحاول ان تستخدم الورق
الكرديه في كيفيه التعاطي مع هذا الملف
البكاء مع سوريا وتواجدهم داخل اراضي
سوريا والعراقيه لذلك هي المصالح المشتركه
انا بين هلالين نسميها الامن القومي لهذه
الدول لذلك طالما ما كان والكوره كعب
بعيدا عن الحركات السياسيه طالما ما كان
الكره ضحيه لهذه الاتفاقيات السياسيه لذلك
انا اعتقد بان همم قرار الرئيس التركي بان
يذهب الى حذاء يعني نشر حزام امني من
الشرق الى الغرب على الحدود السوريه
هذه ورقه الضغط واشتغل على الحكومه
السوريه ان خضعت حكومه السوريه المطالب
التركيه بالتاكيد سيكون هناك تقارب بين
الطرفين والعكس صحيح لكن لا اعتقد بان
الكرد هما حلق قويه في هذا الصراع وهذا ما
كانت عليه في تجارب جميعا لذلك نحن نعتقد
بان يعني الضرر سيقع على الكره بالتالي
دكتور ذكير همم ضيفي منذ قليل للاستاذ عبد
الحميد وضح بصفه اا صريحه همم ما قراه من
مطالب سوريا هو يقول بان ليس هناك همم
موانع لعوده العلاقه متينه ولكن هناك ملف
شائك همم هناك مفخخات ومن بينها ملف
الاكراد ملف الاكراد في الواقع همم تساميه
تركيا ملف سجادي يسميه السوريون واستعمل
المصطلح منذ قليل ضيفي استعمار كيف سيلتقي
الطرفان في نقطه شائكه كهذه
سيدتي العزيزه اذا ذهبنا الى اتفاقيه اضنه
قبل سنين كانت هناك بين الطرفين مشاكل
الاكثر من الان بكثير ولكن كيف اتفقوا في
النهايه وبدون حتى لا روسيا ولا دوله اخرى
كان هناك حوار متبادل من الطرفين لذلك اي
اي لقاء بين الدول او بين مسؤولين لابد
تحتاج الى
تنازلات هذه التنازلات همم تكون من
الطرفين وليس من الطرف الواحد يعني لان
هذا كانت
حتى الجلوس صحيح ولكن حتى لا نتكلم
بعموميات خلينا ندخل لجوهر الموضوع ونسمي
ال- ال- الاشياء بالمسمياتها تنازلات
تركيا تطلب اي تنازلات وقادر على اعطاء
ماذا مثلا لان النظام السوري في هذا
القطار
يعني
اولا دعيني اولا اشير الى هذه التنازلات
يعني يجب معرفتها من النظام يعني
ضيفك الكريم او انا حتى بعض الاحيان ربما
اقول شيئا ولكن لابد النظر بان هل هذه
الادعاءات كلها مطلوبه من الطرف السوري او
وهي مطلوبه من الطرف التركي ام لا اولا
ثانيا لابد ان تكون هذه
الطلبات خطوه خطوه وليست كلها مره يعني
لابد تحتاج الى حوارات وليس حوار يعني
اعطيكم رساله من خلال العشره ايام القادمه
سوف يكون هناك لقاء بين مسؤول تركيا
ومسؤول سوري همم لكن هذا دبلوماسي وليس
همم استخباراتيه همم هذا يعني يعني همم
تقارب خطوه خطوه الى الامام ولكن هذا في
نفس الوقت دكتور لا زال الكلام
فقط للتفاعل همم عام همم طرحنا ملف
الاكراد كيف يمكن حل هذا الملف خطوه خطوه
المثال همم
تركيا تقول همم ليس لديها مانع بالنسبه
للحقوق التي يطالب بها الاكراد في سوريا
او في تركيا وهي مستعده ان تكون ضامن حتى
لهذه الحقوق لان عنا في تركيا نسبه عاليه
من اصول كرديه
وتربطون على قناه جيده جدا معهم فلذلك همم
تكون في نفس الشكل في سوريا ايضا همم يعني
تركيا همم قبل اندلاع الثوره طلبت من
الحكومه السوريه بعد الطلبات باسم الاكراد
وليست من جديد لتحسين اوضاعهم من الجنسيه
الى الوضع السياسي الى الوضع الاجتماعي
الى الوضع الاقتصادي ولكن للاسف الشديد
حتى كانت هناك لقاءات مكثفه بين همم الذين
ما زال يدعون بانهم يمثلون الاحزاب
الكرديه في سوريا نعم داخل تركيا
من الداخل صحيح ولكن اكراد الداخل وليست
اكراد وليس اكراد الحدود ولكن هذه النقطه
وساده عبد الحميد هل يمكن ان يتفاعل معها
النظام السوري ان كان هذا الملف من اكثر
الملفات الشائكه هل يمكن تعامل معه
تدريجيا او عبر مراحل كما تفضل بالاشاره
الدكتور بكير
العلاقات السياسيه او السياسه عموما تقتضي
ان يكون هناك تدرج في همم بناء ركائز
التفاهمات لكن الذي يقصده انا وواقع الحال
يقول بانه هناك ملفات كثيره همم
تتجنب بجانب التركي الخوض بها على المستوى
السياسي الرسمي وذهب فورا للقفز
ان هناك العلاقات نستعيدها والاخيره وهي
اعتقد ان ذات هذه المواقف التي طرحت في
اطارها
همم تكتيكي ذا الطابع او بواعث محليه
الواقع القائمه الان اذا ارد انا اتساءل
انا كمواطن عربي سوري ان نتساءل كيف يمكن
ان تعود العلاقات الى ما كانت عليه وتركيه
تحتل شريط الحدوديه
بمسافه تقدر ب 22 كم مربعا وقليلا كيف لي
ان همم اتخلص على سبيل المثال من عبء
حكايه اللاجئين التي باتت ملفا داخليا
تركيا على اعتاب همم الانتخابات وباتت
محطه صراعا ومنافسه بين الاحزاب التركيه
كلها
ماذا افعل على الورقه الكرديه الان في
سوريا في شرق ال ال الفرات في الشمال
الشرقي السوري تركيا تقول بانهم منظم
ارهابيه وتقاتلهم حتى
تصل الى حدود 30 كم في العمر والجانب
السوري يقول بانه مكون اجتماعي سوري ولكن
لابد من ان يد يعطي الثقه والطمانينه
لدمشق ولي الدوله السوريه بانه غير
انفصاله وانه يجب قطع علاقته مع الامريكان
ويجب ان لا يكون راس حربه في المشروع
الامريكي في سوريا تحديدا وبالتالي يعتقد
ان هذه التشابهات لا شك اعود واقول
السياسه تبنى بهدوء وبخطوه خطوه ولكن
اعتقد ان الملف السوري التركي واعلم جيدا
بان ايضا بان الجانب الروسي يبذل وجوده
بشكل كبير بلوره قواسم مشتركه بين الطرفين
على املي بنائي
همم
الاطراف الاخرى ليست بتلك الاهميه سبق وان
التقينا سبق وان كانت هناك نقاشات
ومفاوضات ثنائيه وتوصلنا الى حلول باختصار
استاذ عبد الحميد ردك على هذه النقطه
نعم اعتقد بان هذا كان هناك يحتاج الى
توضيح الاتفاقيه اعطنا الامنيه وسميت
ارضنا الامنيه في عام في شهر تشرين ثاني
1998 ابانا ازمه عبد الله اوجلان في دمشق
وخروجه وصلت جانب التركي وكانت الاحزاب
القوميه هي التي تحكم وصلت الى حشد الجيوش
وتدخل الرئيس المصري الراحل حسني مبارك
وقبل الرئيس السوري الراحل حافظ الاسد
وساطه الرئيس المصري حسني مبارك وخلال
اسبوع كان حسني مبارك قد زار بين انقر
ودمشق اكثر من اربع مرات الى ان توصل لهذه
الاتفاقيه والتي سميت بالتفاقيه اظن
الامنيه وتسمح للجانب التركي بالتوجه
الخمسه كيلو متر في الاراضي السوريه من
خلال التنسيق مع الجانب الامن السوري
لمطاردته من يصفها بالارهابيين اذا كانوا
موجودين في تلك المنطقه اعتقد اليهم الامر
مختلف تماما وليس له لا يمكن مقاربته او
مقارته مع واقع الحالي اليوم من عام 19 98
اتفاقيه اضنه على واقع الحال تركيا لم تكن
تحتل الشمال السوري او جزء كبير من الشمال
السوري تركيا لم تكن تدير معارضه مسلحه
بهذه الاتجاه وتصحيح لمعلومه ضيفك الكريم
التركيه تركيه حين قبل الاحداث حين ارادت
التدخلت مع الجانب السوري ليس بادخال
الاتراك كمكون في السياسه السوريه طلبت
ادخال عناصر من تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين في
الحكومه السوريه وكان الرفض السوري قاطعا
لهذا الامر يبدو بانك موافق على كل هذا
استاذ محمود
لا صراحه يعني انا لدي يعني ملاحظه لربما
نحن نخوض في مساله في عقد تاريخي سابق وان
المعادلات السياسيه الاقتصاديه الامنيه
تغيرت سواء ما يتعلق بسوريا او بتركيا
وحتى في المنطقه الزمام المبادره ليست
بيرك تركيا وليست بيه السوريه هناك عوامل
ذكرت في البدايه اوامر المخرطه في العام
بين تركيا وسوريا الان سوريا لا تستطيع ان
تقوم باي تفاوض ولا تستقوم باي اتفاق مع
تركيا دون موافقه على الاقل روسيا وكذلك
تواجد الامريكي يعني هناك بما يقارب الف
مقاتل امريكي على الاراضي السوريه هناك
يعني تتجمع في سوريا لمحاربه الارهاب هناك
الرؤيه التركيه هناك ازمه الطاقه في
العالم وذلك المعادله ليست بهذه الطريقه
هنتكلم وكاننا في درس تاريخي ونتكلم عن
الامور الى ربما الاعلى ليست حاضره في
المعادله السياسيه لمعادله تغيرت نحتاج
الى يعني ترتيب الاولويات وفقه ما هي
موجوده الكورد هم ضحيه يقول لهم مره اخرى
ضحيه لماذا لان المصالح المشتركه
وبما تسمى بين هلال بالامن القومي لهذه
الدول لي تصب في الجهه المضاده للحقوق
الكرديه لذلك اعتقد بان كل ما اتضحت
الرؤيه اكثر يجب ان يكون هناك تلاقي
للمصالح بين هذه بين هذه الاقطاب
المتسارعه الكرد في سوريا بغض النظر
اقولهم مره اخرى عن الحزب العمال
الكورساني او غير يجب ان يكون هناك حوار
جاد برعايه امريكيه الروسيه صراحه كل من
يعول على عدم الحضور الروسي الامريكي في
الحوار التركي السوري الكردي بالتكييف هو
يعني لا نريد نقول غافلا عن الحقيقه لكن
يحاول ان يلي عنق الحقيقه ان نقول هو مره
اخرى هذه التوجات اللي موجوده هنا همم
يعني وصلت قبل ما قبل قليل بان حكومه
التركيه سحبت الفرقه الصحفيه الموجوده في
الشريط الحدودي وتعتمد على المحللين
المحليين وهذا دلاله على ان تركيا جاد في
العمليه البريه في المستقبل وان الحكومه
السوريه لا تستطيع ايقاف ذلك وحتى الى كان
هناك تقارب سوري تركي سيكون بعد العمليه
التركيه لذلك هذه اوراق الضغط يستخدمه جهه
مع جهه اخرى تستخدمها تركيا ضد سوريا
وسوريه تستخدم الكره ضد التركي
استاذ محمود ولكن تعليق ولكن استاذ عبد
الحميد باختصار شديد لو سمحت
انا اعتقد بان العمليه التي يلوح بها
الجانب التركي ضد الاكراد لن تغير
الاستراتيجيه السوريه تجاه
[موسيقى]
الخصمين او العدوان التركي
للمعادله اليوم هذه المتغيرات سحبت البساط
من تحت النظام السوري وليس المقرر الوحيد
نتحدث عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وروسيا كذلك ونستذكر بانه هناك طريق
امدادات عسكريه مهم جدا الان 4 يمر من
الشمال الذي تود تركيا توغل بيه همم فكيف
سيتحرك نظام السوري في ظل هذه المتغيرات
ولا يستطيع عاقل ان ينكره ولكن اعتقد بان
طبيعه العلاقه التركيه العلاقه السوريه
الروسيه اليوم والمصالح الروسيه العليا
تقتضي ان تقومي هي بهذه بهذا الدور سوريا
لوحدها لا تستطيع ان تقبل العمليه البريه
ضد الاتراك وسوريا لوحدها لا تستطيع ان
تستخدم الاوراق حاليا
وبالتالي هذه العوامل والمتغيرات الواقعه
على همم الان والقائمه الان لها تاثير
مباشره والعامل الامريكي عامل مرجح لكل
هذه التصور
الى نقطه اخرى من هذا النقاش
همم يعني للاسف الشديد ضيفك من دمشق يصر
على ان يبقى في الماضي لا يريد المستقبل
وانا نعم اعطيت امثله كيف حصلت هناك مع
اني
تشابه ولكن ليست بمعنى اخر كما يدعي هو
اني اصبح كذا وكذا وكذا يعني بالتفاصيل
نعم التاريخ بعض الاحيان يعطي دروسا
للمستقبل ولكن بدون ان البقاء فيها بشكل
دائم هناك مستجدات كما ذكر ضيفك من اربيل
ايضا وهذه المستجدات ربما سوف تعطي بنفس
الوقت همم ادوارا مختلفه ان كانت لتركيا
ان كانت الكورن ان كانت في سوريا ان كانت
لامريكا ولي روسيا ايضا وهذه همم
تستوجب يعني تحديث
الرؤى والاجتماعات والحوارات اذا كانت قبل
خمس سنين او عشر سنين كيف نشط والانفسه
النقطه ولكن همم دكتور بكير كان هناك ورقه
قويه بيد سوريه وهي استعمال القرد ضد
تركيا الان اصبح العكس فاذن هل تصر سوريا
على نفس الشيء اذا همم تغيرات كبيره وليست
صغيره لذلك اللعبه تحتاج مره
ضيف يتحدث عن المطامع الداخليه للرئيس
اردوغان هو تحدث او المحا الى الانتخابات
ان انقل لك استطلاعات راي تؤكد هذا الموقف
او هذه القراءه استطاعات الراي الاخيره
جرت منذ اسبوعين تقريبا همم اجرتها شركه
ماركه تركيه للدراسات واستطاعات الراي
بعنوان دراسه اجندا التركيه سالوه الاتراك
ان كان اردوغان ضد منافس سترشحون من
لرئاسه تركيا 36 سيسوطون اردوغان 14 لم
يقرروا بعد ولكن غريب بانه 44 يساوي صوت
منافس اردوغان اي من كان من دون معرفه من
هو سيصوطن له فشعبيه اردوغان في تراجع
تبتسم دكتور بكير ولكن هذه استطاعات راي
من الداخل التركي على فكره ونشرتها صحيفه
زمن التركيه فهل يمكن لاردوغان ان يسارع
ويهرول باتجاه نظام السوري لهذه الدوافع
للانتخابات
يعني وليست راي فقط راي همم هذه الجريده
وليست راي العام الموجود لان اليوم موجوده
ايضا وعلى هذه الاستطلاعات تعتبر في الطرف
المعارض لرئاسه اردوغان ايه هناك 42%
لصالح اردوغان واا 29 لصالح المعارضه على
كل هذه الارقام لا يؤخذ بعينيا
42% لا همم ما فيش تراجع لان هذه العشره
في ال 100 لشخصيه اردوغان وليس للحزب هنا
واضح جدا في جميع الانتخابات التي حصلت في
تركيا الحزب همم يعني همم شعبيه اردوغان
اكثر من الحزب وليست لل جميع الانتخابات
التي حصلت الى الان والتي سوف تحصل في
الايام القادمه فاذا اردوغان على سبيل
المثال لن يترشح هذا الحزب نعم 40 42 ممكن
لكن اذا ترشح اردوغان فهذه الاحصائيات
تزيد 10% لان هذه ارقام شخصيه وليست للحزب
وهذه واضحه على كل يعني الايام الانتخابات
سوف تشرق قريبا وسوف نجد النتيجه مع بعض
واتمنى اتمنى هذه الارقام التي تقولونها
ان تكون صحيحه لاني ايضا انا اريد التغيير
هذا التغيير ولكن اريد التغيير ليس بمعنى
ان ياتي هؤلاء المرشحين الان الذين هم
بعيدين تماما ليس فقط في همم ضد اردوغان
وانما اتمنى ان ان يكون فعلا
لبناء تركيا الحديثه للتغيير الاقتصادي
والسياسي التي تحتاجها المنطقه والعالم
كلها لذلك ادعيني يشير الى نقطه باختصار
طيب تفضل لانه انتهى تماما الوقت نحن
نتحدث عن الانتخابات وتفقد همم ان اختم مع
الاستاذ
بل ذلك ارجو هذه الانتخابات فقط استاذ عبد
الحميد هل يتانى بشار الاسد في تقديم راي
همم الصريح وواضح لانه ينتظر انتخابات
الرئاسيه والتشريعيه كما يقول بعض
انا اعتقد انه قد يكون جزء من ركائز
المنهج السوري او المنهج السياسي السوري
في ما يتعلق بالمساله التركيه ولكن لا
اعتقد انه هناك تعويلا همم كاملا وتاما
على هذه النتائج وعلى هذه الانتخابات
الاهم بالنسبه اعتقد بالنسبه لدمشق في هذه
المرحله هو الاستعداد لصياغه علاقه
متوازنه ولكن تقوم على احترام الحقوق وعلى
همم سحاب التركي من الاراضي التي همم
السوريه التي يحتلها وسحب مشروعيه
ايضا من تلك المنطقه سواء كانتريكا او
محاوله تغيير العمله السوريه في بعض
المناطق في الاراضي السوريه التي تسيطر
عليها تركيا اعتقد بان هناك العوامل همم
في هذه في هذا الملف الامريكي والروسي
والتركي والكردي والسوري اعتقد كله الان
في حاله تداخل وتشابك
واشتباكيه شكرا لك عبد الحميد توفيق صحفي
الشكر لضيفه من اسطنبول والاكيد ستبقى لنا
نقاشات اخرى دكتور بكرا تجان مدير معهد
اسطنبول للفكر وسننتظر نتائج الانتخابات
وشكر لضيفنا من همم اربيل محمود خشنه
السياسي الكردي شكرا لكم